one thing that occurs to me when I watch
Big Mouth because I'm I know you and and
and mr. Mulaney and I and I know a bunch
and you're always your two characters
are always having to make embarrassing
sounds as voice-over artist in a cartoon
but you're constantly having orgasms or
about to have an orgasm and I think when
you're recording that and you're an
adult male are you embarrassed when
you're in that in that room making those
noises um well I'm about to do it right
here on the stage it's gonna be a quiet
one just one little tear two separate
little tears two separate tears that
join up down here so stupid yeah now I
have to apologize did that that was
really childish and it was it was a
different time you'd have learned a lot
as a friend of Conan I would like to say
I know that he's changed yeah like you
hear there's so many like so many
orgasms specifically Mulaney as Andrew
because Andrew is the character in the
show who's constantly masturbating yeah
yeah and so you're constantly hearing
him yes
I guess the I mean the colloquial term
would be to blow his load so
that we will cut out so anyway what else
so he but you do hear all the different
versions of how one could orgasm yeah
and so I've now heard every version of
it like ecstatic very depressed
surprised I've heard all of them I've
heard every single one of joy surprise
orgasm
[Laughter]